i have the
i have a somewhat challenge here that
we've got about whatever 45 minutes or
so
and i'd like very much to address some
of the things that are on your mind
because having been at the forefront of
the solar industry for the last i guess
10 years or so there's a lot of exciting
things that i hope to share with you
today
um so even though this is an engineering
class i think the first thing we do have
to start off with is
cost and it looks like this is something
that all of you are probably
um you know knowledgeable about but
basically
the um the solar technology has actually
been around for quite some time
and the reason that the last decade or
so has
seen popularity of solar energy and its
installations
is primarily cost so as you were
mentioning earlier and that which you've
covered in your solar
cell class is that it's really very
much a cost driven industry and you look
at this kind of a dramatic
change you know was there a
change in physics that happened between
1980 and year 2000
no there wasn't it was just a matter of
it's still a
you know a pn junction a very simple
device
from electrical engineering perspective
this is not complicated
it's all about how do you deploy it and
what volume
is it being deployed in that can
actually drive the cost
down and unfortunately for us
we are now at the point that module
prices are below a dollar in fact
they're well below a dollar
so much of what you um um hear about
where there's additional pressure for
cost certainly there is
you know it's it's it's a commodity and
so there's a
you know there's a continuous drive to
excel
um but really if you look at this curve
there's a lot that's been done regarding
cost already and we'll touch upon that
throughout the presentation but what is
what happens when you have
a dramatic increase in cost like this is
that you've got
you all of a sudden a huge market right
you drive down a very simple kind of
you know economics um you drive down
costs and all of a sudden demand goes up
um so what's happened is that um
in 2006 we had 1.5 gigawatts of solar
and um you know um
i guess five whatever the number of
years that is
nine eight years eight years later um
we're looking at
52 and um
and you know you look at other
industries like nuclear
there's no there's no such growth like
this there's a huge installed base and
there's a lot of gigawatts of power that
are generated using nuclear energy but
if you look at the growth over the last
you know decade or so there has not been
this um
so this is a pretty unique and very
special situation
the u.s has been lagging behind
um of some of the other countries that
were mentioned japan is a
was an early adopter and then germany
really is one of the
main places that gets credit for
changing their policies to really drive
the
the engine for cost reduction but the us
actually if you look in just like three
years
it has an amazing multiplier of how much
um you know interest and installed
energy
there is in uh for solar
so if you know staying a little bit with
the u.s
california kind of leads the charge here
um and there's a couple of states in
there that might surprise you new jersey
but it really is again comes down to
policy there was
some governor there who established a
policy to incentivize people and
you put the right incentives and reward
systems in place human beings line up
right behind it
and so that's basically what you've seen
but i've been some of the other ones are
more
um you know there's more logic just as
far as how much sunshine there is
hawaii the cost of power is very
expensive and so
you're kind of getting to grid parity um
is uh is easier there
for solar and um but anyway this kind of
gives you a little bit of a breakdown
like rooftop as well this is mostly yeah
this is mostly
residential as well as yeah it's the
total installed
but this really is um the story here
um there are in silicon valley we're
lucky enough to have had experiences of
this kind of growth in other industries
but really this is not something that
you expect in your lifetime to
be able to participate in and so i find
it very fortunate
as a technical person to have
um experiences i entered the industry
around
2006 time frame and so literally
the um you know there was a 10x
multiplier in installed capacity this is
manufacturing capacity
and um and it really was an
amazing experience to be um involved
and um uh and but you know
this is it's this is this is not slowing
down um
even though that over the last couple
years we've seen a lot of
um you know fluctuation in the
marketplace if you just think about the
value that solar energy brings
to the energy portfolio that the world
needs
it's it's um you know the
the inherent value of it is really
reflected here
and no matter how in the near term
people
wonder okay you know should i invest in
these solar companies or
should we put solar on our roof right
now or next year what will the policy be
there's a lot of like near-term
questions but in the long run
everybody recognizes that solar is
bringing real value to the energy needs
that we have
on um you know across the world and it's
expected to be a trillion dollar
industry
by 2013.
okay so um leslie mentioned and i wanted
to definitely give you know all of you
are our in early in your careers and so
i wanted to give you a little bit of an
idea of what my experience has been
and and the you know where um and how
roller solar energy has played a role so
i
was born and bred actually in berkeley
as well but i
finished my phd back in at the end of
the 90s and at that time you know solar
was
definitely you know an area that some of
my colleagues were studying
um i remember a couple a couple of
people in you know professor haller's
group
and um iq waivers group there would be
silicon and people would talk about
you know the conversion efficiencies
but still it wasn't really it was always
seen as
a technology that you know had this cost
challenge
and um and so from a kind of an academic
perspective
um i i chose to study nanotubes
and um and you know um
finished up my phd and went straight
into industry rather than pursuing
an academic route which is i guess more
typical for physics
and my main reason to do that was
because i
i liked the um the
the motivation to actually take
technology and bring it
to people to to value in a product
was personally more motivating to me
than to kind of go deeper and deeper
into
doing research and and
so and i think this mentality actually
plays well with solar energy because a
lot of it is
it's not as much the basic science that
you're learning but really it's kind of
how are you driving down the cost curve
how are you driving up the efficiency
curve
that type of a problem so i
actually end up joining applied
materials and
it was a great time to be there because
the industry was moving from
a car from aluminum to copper and so
there were a lot of
new projects and i got i went from the
world of
resource constrained in grad school to
lots of resources
at your fingertips and you know as you
ask for different chemicals or gases by
the time you get to the lab four hours
later there are the gases are all
already hooked up and you can do
whatever experiments you want so it's a
really great environment to
to get started on an industrial career
and then i joined agilent and that's
where leslie and i had a chance to meet
and work together and
around 200 and 2003 time frame
i had the opportunity to follow up on
some of the research that i done in
nanotechnology
and i wrote a business plan and founded
a company to do
electronics cooling using nanotubes so
this really kind of
um changed a lot of my technical focus
to also having a business focus
and and again i think the environment
around here in silicon valley is
something that
you really i mean i would encourage you
all to take advantage of
it's not every place that you can you
know go out there and
anybody you run into in a coffee shop
you'll be able to have a conversation
regarding some experience that they have
related to a to a startup or a
a business plan or a new technology and
you know these this is an environment
that's very rich for that
um so so i had the opportunity it was
it was funded by top-tier investors we
went through we hired a team we took the
technology to where
the materials were like world-class but
the
implementation of the market was
actually different than what we expected
and so i ended up um
i had i had basically as part of the
business plan had had
sold my patents to the investors and so
they gave me back my patents and
i ended up returning part of the money
um most startups don't end this way
either they they will run out of money
but i
i actually stopped midway because time
is more valuable than money so
once i knew there was a market risk i
didn't want to actually keep going and
waste the time with the great team that
i'd hired and or my investors or myself
and and that's where i was looking for a
very interesting technology problem
which had a business application
and solar was really kind of in its
prime at that point
um so i joined sun power and there were
400 people when i joined and there were
4 000 people when i left so it was just
that that 10x growth that you saw
as far as the installed capacity you
experienced that on every level
and and i can speak more to some of the
issues that you guys brought up but kind
of fast forwarding a little bit
i ended up after a couple years at sun
power
being recruited into a startup that was
doing gallium arsenide
which has the world record efficiency
for um
for single cell single junction solar
cells
and um and spent five years there until
it was acquired
um in earlier this year and then now i'm
at apple so
anyway solar is um is definitely
um in a it's a it's a fantastic field
and i encourage all of you to
you know um take advantage of this
time that you have in um at stanford to
get connected to
both classes as well as industry okay so
solar technology
um you're pretty much familiar it seems
like everybody kind of has the
background in it you know it's
a panel it's not very space efficient
a light bulb like this will actually
generate about the same wattage as
a panel um but but
on the other hand um once you've you've
put the energy
into making this panel it'll continue to
you know power up and and we um
the efficiency is where you've got over
at the approximately one square meter is
about 100 to
200 watts depending on what kind of
technology you're using
so you know operation wise uh solar
shell is very simple like i mentioned
it's a you know
pn diode and um and basically the sun
comes in
generates an electron hole pair you put
contacts on
and you generate a current so not much
you can do
but actually the whole point is that all
you can do is you're just
fighting physics for the losses so
everything you do in solar cell design
in optimizing is basically you're trying
to have less and less loss
you will have loss but the better you
design your device
and the more the more fine-tuned your
manufacturing process
the the more efficient your solar cell
will be but
you're you know silicon
um you know the best you can get is skin
is around 30
even in a kind of a you know theoretical
limit
so to the point of like wait you know
can't we do better or
there's so much power coming out of the
sun well from a solar
perspective yes you can you can capture
a part of that but
you're always you know the the amount
that you capture
you should have your expectations um
within around the 30
range and 20 is where the industry's at
right now
um overall solar cell design i think
maybe you've covered a lot of this in
some of your other classes but
you know what's important is that you do
texturing so that
the light that's come in you try to get
as much out of it as possible
the the beam will bounce multiple times
and so you can get
more um you can generate more electron
hole pairs
um so tight so jet so and this is how
good is your
text drink so now there's a
manufacturing process that
you know certain set of certain
companies have equipment and different
chemistries and
if you buy this tool you'll get this
level of texturing you buy another tool
you'll get another level of texturing
and how well that works with the rest of
your solar cell design it's
there's a lot of research and effort
that
um that the various um
you know that industry has already um
you know tried to optimize substantially
um in fact uh
the one of the um
okay well so so conventionally you've
got this the the the this is the slide
is basically telling you what kind of
losses you have
i covered this a little bit already
you've got a limit about 30 percent
and generally you're looking at about a
20 percent efficient solar cell
i had the good fortune of working at
sunpower
and this is where we had an all back
contact solar cell design that actually
came out of stanford
and and dick swanson founded the company
actually i think 20 years ago or
something like that and it was only in
the last you know decade or so that
really
with the policy changes um around the
world
that it was really able to to grow
the way that it has and there you've got
a unique design where the front
is now there's no shadowing with
electrical contacts it's all in the back
it does require
more sophisticated manufacturing so
there is a increase
in the complexity but at a net what
you're getting and this is like all the
math that you do
for the energy that's harvested in
on the top of a rooftop so given a
certain square footage and how much
power you can generate
you're really at a net positive with
this technology
and i guess in the question session i'll
i'll
entertain specific questions rather than
going more deeply into it
at this point so the value chain
um the you know you start off with
silicon and yes
it costs a lot of energy to to generate
the silicon
um on the other hand the if you look at
the semiconductor industry they've
already put a lot of effort into
driving those costs down and getting
really high quality silicon with the
least amount of defects and
for solar you actually don't need the
kind of quality that you need for a lot
of the semiconductor devices
so you're able to to grow
you're able to change the growth
processes to a certain extent to have
more production and
in fact you know the industry if you
recall in the first graph would you have
the module prices went up a little bit
it was all because there was such an
incredible demand from the solar end
industry
that the silicon industry didn't expect
it and so they were sitting here
you know making their predictions based
on semiconductor and then solar comes
and kind of overwhelms it and so there
was a
there was a uh you know a jump in the
silicon prices
raw you know silicon was going for
a kilogram for spot prices which right
now are more
closer to the 25 dollar mark so it was
it was quite some crazy times um
but the base of um you know
the the base technology there's some
improvements that people have tried to
make in
um they're single crystal silicon cells
that can be made but there's also
polycrystalline
and the the um the multi-crystalline
cells
the bigger you can get your grain size
the better and so there's quite a bit of
effort that has been
made on the on the growth side to see if
you can get higher quality
lower quality silicon so increase the
quality of the multi crystalline
and then it's all about this processing
so that middle block that accounts for
about 15 percent
of um of the cost is
really where a lot of effort is put
and has been
a driver for the volume something that
doesn't really come up
a lot in in solar cell discussions
is when you look at how this this cost
curve
you know what has really enabled it to
be driven down so low
personally i feel like the credit should
a lot of credit should go to the
equipment manufacturers
and of course the researchers that have
optimized the design that's a really big
you know the they they get a lot of the
credit
but also the equipment suppliers have
really
maintained the high performance of the
processes that are coming out and yet
scale the equipment to much larger
you know production volumes so for
example you have a
wet tool that used to run a thousand
wafers
an hour at a certain cost
now that same tool can run three to four
thousand wafers an hour and it's just
marginally a little bit more expensive
and the quality of the processes coming
out of that are not that different
so and and now when somebody is you know
you look at the you saw that growth from
1.5 gigawatts to
you know 50 plus gigawatts of installed
capacity
you know you can't that's a you know you
would have to put in four tools for
every one tool that they actually did
end up putting in
so that kind of manufacturing equipment
design
um is uh you know as
gets a lot of credit in my mind and um
and
you know um the semiconductor industry
has
traditionally also been support well
supported by the equipment industry
and equipment's you know it's tough
business it's it's expensive
to um to build equipment
um there's um there's
you know it takes time so you can't like
it's not like
you know six like one month and you get
a new product and you
you know sell it's like it takes six
months to build this stuff um
and um and you know you get profit but
on the other hand with
and if you're if you're serving an
industry that is very cost sensitive
you know we were negotiating some very
um
you know um very good prices so the
equipment guys were not making the kind
of margin
that the semiconductor equipment people
were making so
in fact when the market went down they
they
suffered a lot there's many of those you
know fantastic companies
that have really been struggling to
survive
this downturn so you know that's that's
part of the um
the story if you've got something so
dynamic
um then panel making is when you've
actually got the solar cell it's
you know individually it's got the
electrical contacts on it but now you
need to put it in
series onto a panel and there's a
substantial cost that goes into that and
that's also
a place where people have made you know
good progress in driving down you know
exactly how much um
ribbon you really need and what's the
best ways of putting it together so you
have the least amount of losses
um and then if you look at that
downstream it's like a huge amount of
cost goes into
and i think somebody mentioned here you
know the
the installation and the inverters and a
lot of the
rest of the um the system
and there i think it's also regional um
and and again as you've got
companies like solarcity um they you
know they're optimizing this
you know more and more by having people
who can
come out to homes and very quickly show
the value proposition
it used to be that it was hard you know
you're kind of like okay do i do
to i should i install solar or should i
not install stroller how am i gonna fund
it you know all these type of questions
come into this
and the models for doing that have
gotten much more sophisticated over the
last few years which has
you know supported the growth of the
market
but overall it's all about kind of cost
per watt um
and earlier used to just be dollars per
watt and now people are getting a little
bit smarter and kind of you know
are looking at dollars per kilowatt hour
and
and so um you know it's uh and then
that's you know
it's obviously more accurate to to see
the actual energy that's harvested
um so that's that kind of applies to
um mostly to the silicon industry but i
also want to point out that there's thin
film
and so thin film
has been also a very interesting story
where
it's always been a smaller portion of
the market but there's been a couple of
companies that have really
made substantial progress and it's
really been a simpler manufacturing
um you know flow and
that has enabled this so even though
it's less efficient from a panel
level it's actually more cost effective
because your
manufacturing processes are really
straightforward you don't start off with
silicon you just start off with glass
well guess what
you're going to take your solar cells in
and you know
sandwich them into pieces of glass
anyway so why not just have the glass
so these kind of you know uh
differences make thin film also quite
compelling
amorphous silicon um they're you know
that's a technology
that has been out there has been
struggling and in fact
maybe not so popular these days most of
those lines are shut down
sigs is an area i'll talk about a little
in a little bit
where this area specifically silicon
valley had a lot of startups working in
this space
cadtel has been the most successful
which has been first solar
predominantly and then i mentioned the
startup that i was in this was
alto devices and we worked on a gallium
arsenide
this is a fascinating technology because
every kind of buzzword you thought of in
silicon and as
in solar industry high efficiency it has
it flexible
it has it thin film it has it cost
effective it has it
you know you it was a little bit like
wait is this for real
and then you know you spend five years
on it and yes it is for real
um so so anyway but generally
the market still is heavily biased
towards
silicon valley
yes it shows up on both sides because um
uh
the space cells are also gallium
arsenide
so all of your you know um
systems out in um you know
all satellites and stuff they're all
powered by youngsters
pardon me i work on space station solar
array and i've oversaw the production of
these cells
is that right okay yeah so but the
government and everything that goes into
space is
more expensive i can't even tell you how
many indians we threw away because they
suspected they might have flaws
yeah you know for sure and then when
they grew the crystals
they couldn't explain why they had to
throw something away they said
we just think it's wrong we're throwing
it away but they had the money
yeah yeah i mean that's just that's a
that's um an area where
there's no cost sensitivity so it's or
yeah
that's right is it yeah
right the repairman that's a long way to
go right exactly so you just basically
it's kind of a no risk mentality
can go away if you have a minor failure
that makes it into the public domain
so yeah or or or the following they're
like oh
you guys had a problem with it we're
going to cut your funding off we're
going to go find something else
and you know a simple number if you want
to keep in mind is
a gallium arsenide wafer is about 150
and a silicon wafer is about four
dollars
so um that's partially you know um
but it has the highest efficiency and so
if you're up in space
you want to get the most out of you know
whatever sun you're going to collect so
it shows up both places okay
um so the next day you know so we kind
of talked a little bit about
um the technology this next set of
slides
is really kind of more in the
application domain
and some that are currently
you know emerging and others that are
maybe more
future term but it gives you the
possibilities of what solar energy
connect
can do in these different fields
so this is the the traditional market
here is
residential um power plants
um and commercial so commercial is
basically you've got target and it's got
you know solar cells on it well it's
really great actually because
they cut down their peak power you can't
have the whole power of the
you know the plant be run by solar but
you can cut down the peak power and it
makes a tremendous difference from a
cost perspective facilities
people love it power plants you know
this is where you take a
big open field and usually it's out in
the middle of the desert because it's
the
most the best return for energy
harvesting
and uh but you're kind of far away and
so you still have all the transmission
losses residential is great because you
know you generate it and you use it so
you've you're really kind of minimizing
the loss in the system you already have
the losses from
the solar cell so
so this is a very compelling value
proposition and particularly if you look
at other parts of the world
where you don't have an established grid
well this is
this is a ready set um solution
what has really been um you know
of interest to people and more and more
people
as in over the last few years is really
the portable market
and there has always been some
technology like amorphous silicon that
you can
you can build solar cells on flexible
substrates the problem though is that
you need to have like a
huge um you know uh piece
of material in order to get some
substantial power so all of a sudden the
portability is there okay so you can you
know it's flexible but on the other hand
and if you really want some substantial
power you really need to be lugging
around
quite a volume of material
but with the gallium arsenide solar
cells that i was talking about
all of a sudden that value proposition
changes substantially and
with some of the six applications you
know technologies as well
this application becomes more compelling
so i want to spend a little bit of time
on this
um so the mobile power application um
first of all you know a lot of times um
you know technologies we see this all
over and over again with
um the the military and the applications
aren't the early early adopters are
often
um you know uh in this in this
military space and in the case of uh
uavs
if you just have the battery you have
about an hour that this
the the uh unmanned um vehicle can move
around
if you put solar on it all of a sudden
it can recharge and you've got
a substantial um value proposition here
uh so so this is kind of a near term and
if you look at the cost um it's it's a
you know
it's a it's a big payback especially
right and again the budgets are more
elastic
uh you can also have them not just in
the air but on the water and you know
you think about remote
play you know remote places how are you
even gonna think about getting power out
there
well solar you know sun's pretty much
everywhere and so
you can see that you'd get power so i
knew that usgs right
we wouldn't have any weather monitoring
on the ocean if it wasn't for solar
and most of the large buoys off
san francisco are all solar and they've
been that way
for probably our whole life almost yeah
out there yeah and then that's what's so
that's what's so you know interesting
about solar energy
it's this the this material and the
technology has been around it's just a
matter of
deployment and that's why it's uh that's
why i found it to be a really great and
very satisfying area
to have worked in because you know each
time
each notch you can drive the cost down
all of a sudden more
more and more markets open up
um more you know
odd ideas um even in space
so you know this is the gallium arsenide
but now if you talk if you think about
flexible and you can wrap it around
um then there's another value
proposition there
there's obviously you know this is i
think this picture gives you
you know this these set of images kind
of shows you
how broad um you know
the the application can be um
and then you think about it out in the
middle of desert how are you gonna get
some
get power and you've got your devices
everyone is hooked up pretty much
um well you know even with some solar on
the back of this
you're going to end up getting some
power continuous
then there are you know uh you get into
more and more niche markets i guess but
again like i said this is kind of more
for
you know the the creative um spirit
and just seeing where i mean power
itself is ubiquitous
and um and solar really you know can
play a
potentially um large role in making this
a reality
so just industrial wise too you've got
sensors
um this one is actually this is pretty
interesting if you
took took the alta device's solar cells
and put it on ipad
the lar the size is large enough that
you actually can get the same
rate of charge as if you plugged in the
wall so all of a sudden now
that you know value proposition starts
becoming
you know more compelling and it is
driven by obviously the efficiencies
um there's um more you can actually i
think
this is still live you can go to the
health devices website
and see that you know for some of these
consumable devices
depending on the kind of usage you have
you can really extend your battery life
you know substantially so you know i
think
the way we use devices changes i mean
these devices even exist
for you know a short while ago and
and now it's all a matter of trying to
address the user's needs
and and you know i think solar has a
play some of you asked about
the transportation and the role that
solar plays
you know unfortunately the amount of
energy it generates is still pretty
small compared to the rooftop
area that is available in a car on the
other hand um
you can definitely um
you can um you can substantiate the
power
and so um you're draining the battery
less so when the car is just parked
you can have um you know conditioning of
the environment so places like arizona
where
your you know car gets very hot um
you can you know if you have solar on
your rooftop it can easily be running a
fan
and um and you know taking care of the
environment
otherwise you have an electric vehicle
and now you're draining the battery to
you know to to run cooling so the
battery stays
you know cool enough so um
solar has a value proposition there um
in areas that you've got more rooftop
you can do more potentially help with uh
transportation where you're
we're moving goods that need um you know
temperature control like refrigeration
it can help alleviate the drain on
the um the rest of the um the power
systems
um so that kind of gives you i mean most
of these are really not
in um they're all kind of in nascent
stages and it
remains to be seen how they
really get implemented and developed and
it really does take a lot of times
you know individuals that are going to
champion a cause and really believe that
hey
we can make this work and then they
optimize for that particular niche
application and then
you know before you know it that niche
application starts becoming more and
more
popular and all of a sudden you can kind
of generate an industry
i would say some of these are um are
opportunities for that kind of
work to happen but when you get into
you know solar manufacturers and what's
been happening i want to talk a little
bit about
kind of the the the work
in the field and um you know the venture
community
right now solar and clean tech is not
very popular
but a couple of years ago was very very
very popular and the
the vcs put six billion dollars into
this
um space and um
basically with zero return so this was
not a very happy investment story
but it was a it kind of shows you that
there was a lot of promise and there was
a lot of enthusiasm because there was a
lot of action
there were a lot of startups that had
new ideas and new ways of putting down
you know cigs and you can you can plate
it and you can
co-evaporate it and you can sputter it
and you can you know there's there you
know from a techno
from a technical perspective there's a
lot of things to um
to find out to explore and and
there seemed to be a value that you
could um extract from it from with the
cost or simplification of manufacturing
processes
cheaper equipment you know all sorts you
know whole array of things
and people were very actively investing
in them um
so just to scan a few years ago there
was a
huge demand for um for engineers
and um you know contributing to the the
solar space
um unfortunately
the um the startups in this area
have not really had the kind of
experience that some of the other
um you know the dot-com industry for
example um has experienced
but um but still i would say i think one
thing
that this table may not show is that
there was a lot of great training that
happened
there was a lot of technology um
uh you know progress um there was
a lot of know-how that was generated
there's a lot more you know there's an
educated population
that knows what it takes to make solar
work
and i think you know the six billion
dollars that the vcs put in there was
not
you know it was actually there there was
a not a
financial return directly but there was
actually
um another substantial return which i
think will play
um in the future to to make
alternative energy valuable
most of the i don't know many of you may
have seen this but most you know the
challenge and this is kind of more for a
startup
perspective but the challenge is really
that chasm here that you see
where you're really trying to you take
an idea you foster it through
various prototypes and you even get a
pilot line and most of those companies
had pile lines here locally
but then now you have to bridge this gap
and it takes substantial funding
to bridge that gap and then once you're
across that then
you can actually self-sustain but you
need this and
and you know solar technology it's it's
a hardware i mean you need to buy
equipment you need to
have facilities that you know space so
this is you know it's capital intensive
and um and so there was not the appetite
in many cases to cross that chasm so
pardon me yeah
so what has happened is basically a lot
of the the larger companies are the ones
that
survived it was difficult for smaller
companies with their new ideas
to kind of maintain um you know business
um keep the doors open but even with the
big companies this is where
you look at this chart this is just over
you know less than five years and look
at how dynamic this industry is
and this is what for me personally it's
very exciting um
but you see here that um
that you've got um in some sense the
same cast of characters
but it's not like intel and you know
over and over the same thing that you
see
this is really um you know it changes
um you know the the fortunes change
um you know quite dramatically and
and in fact if i had you know even
earlier than this
bp solar and shell solar and some of
these people were kind of
you know leader sharp was a huge had the
largest
installed manufacturing capacity for a
very very long time
and then all of a sudden boom things
changed and you know sharp still
you know got dropped down substantially
and then came back up and
it's really been fascinating to watch
some of these
these players but one thing you notice
with the set of names is that um
definitely the solar manufacturing has
been
um you know takes place in this
particular region of the world
and and i think here we have to
recognize that the chinese government
has been
committed to making solar a reality and
and this is what happens when a
government says we do want to do this
they make capital available it's
it's very popular i mean we would go to
shows and you could you have a hundred
thousand people
coming to a solar show and um and
um and you know everybody's excited
about um
doing renewable and and
very quickly the industry has really
shifted
and you know i think the other areas
there's potential hope that they can
also have
a government policy that can encourage
um
manufacturing but on the other hand with
the pressures that you have in cost
you really have to be very selective
about what
projects you choose to do and not to so
how does that work
for instance in china is it individual
consumers or businesses or is it
the government buying these
installations for
cities how is how does that go so um
basically first of all there was uh
anybody who
um wanted to set up a solar
manufacturing plant
was provided with capital to get started
so yeah so you basically you know you
like literally here in the in the
venture community it was
kind of like when i wrote my business
plan and i shopped it around and said
hey
um i'd like to to do you know i'd like
to use carbon nanotubes and cool
electronics it's like oh that sounds
like a good project okay
so uh now here it's like hey look i i've
got you know
um here's my plan to you know rent the
space and
buy this equipment and i'm gonna produce
you know um
half a gigawatt of solar in one year
it's like okay that sounds like a good
thing
so there is capital available for them
to do that and that basically you had
overnight hundreds
of companies and they bought equipment
so the equipment industry
you know had a very steep um
revenue increase and um and there was
very close collaboration and most of
this equipment is actually made
in europe and you know some in the us so
there's very close collaboration between
the chinese manufacturers and the
european equipment manufacturers
which enabled like i mentioned they
really get a lot of credit for making
this industry happen they enabled this
largely um and then the market was
actually back in
either the us and europe and so things
were sold back
and now there's local markets that are
developing and so yeah now there is
governments now the government now is
focusing on incentivizing the
installation
of solar but earlier they were
incentivizing the production of it
and the us you know has kind of never
really figured out exactly what the
policy they want is
and and it shows i mean this chart
directly shows
what governments kind of understood what
the opportunity space was here and which
ones didn't
okay um looking
forward if you look at kind of the um
you know where and some of you brought
this up with you know off-grid and you
know where the solar has its
value you notice here that um
the prediction is certainly that
residential where you can get the
maximum value because you're generating
power right where you're using it
it's is a very compelling value
proposition and um and a great way to
kind of get to grid parity
um but um and again like i i mentioned
earlier
you look at this and you notice that
nobody is doubting the fact that you
know his solar something that's
you know um that's
that happened and you know and it was
like a blip of
in history it's like no this is
something that it's a
technology that has shown um its value
um it's uh it's dramatically
gone down the cost curve there's still
some room to go but you know it gets
harder and harder every year
um and um but there's more and more to
be done on
in the um in the market and kind of
being able to finance it and get it to
different areas
of the world where um where it's valued
sure looking at this chart and seeing
that residential
is such a high percentage and also
knowing that you know solar generates dc
electricity but also a lot of the
electronics we use require
dc energy and we're converting it the dc
to ac and then the ac back to dc
it do you foresee a
place now where we're building new homes
new
buildings so we're actually going to
install dc wiring we can put solar
directly up to it to minimize those
losses
or is that then too complicated then
plugged back into the grades which is
super conductor
and that may never be affordable
yeah i mean you know this is an area
that people um you know when we're
we're we're working super hard to get
like point zero
five point zero three percent efficiency
um
you know people having to bring up hey
well if you just converted it you know
uh differently you'd get a whole lot
more efficiency than all this research
and all these millions of dollars you're
putting in here
um but that's always it there's really
um
it's kind of a tbd nobody everybody
recognizes that there's a value to it
but nobody really sees
how people are going to actually
implement that um
you know i personally think that there
are um
the the financing of this um
is a near-term um
a near-term value um then actually you
can imagine the infrastructure that you
have to change
not not that it's not possible but it's
a pretty
high bar so i have a feeling that
there's many other things are going to
happen
and then potentially one can always see
this as
a benefit as well but probably will be
able to
garner you know advantage for efficiency
and cost in other ways
inverter i mean there's a lot of work on
micro inverters now
where you're selectively looking at
panels and optimizing
that um the kind of the string of um
of the the solar installation rather
than
you know plugging it all into one
inverter
um so so yeah it's a matter of
when and this one is almost also a
matter of if
it could also be location depend in a
place where you don't have any kind of a
grid maybe there's a different value
proposition
that comes into play there
and um you know the other thing that i
think people should keep in mind and
this is
this is a chart that shows the different
energies and i know many of you kind of
brought this up as well
solar is a very very very very very
small fraction
of the energy mix at the moment
but you know a lot of these other
energies they also had
a lot of policy help and a lot of
support from pardon me
yeah i work in oil right okay so here's
the basic
formula right i mean we like to we can
throw
spears in china for the policies they
have that has wiped out the rest of the
world's solar production
and that was intentional that's what the
chinese wanted to do now they're in a
situation where they have to shut down
the less efficient companies in order to
raise the price again
right and if those some of those
companies were located in the united
states
you know we would love it because
they're actually doing pretty well
in the oil industry if i invest a
hundred thousand dollars
in oil well i can get a hundred percent
of that money back in five years
that currently i can get 70 to 80
percent of that back
in taxes in the first year right i can
do a line item write-off
right there is what else can you do in
the world that does that other than
maybe you know
i don't know you know but but i mean
that's
that's that's not even investment that's
just that
that's a loan okay so even if i give you
a hundred million dollars for your
company and you
go bankrupt i still get all of my money
back
where's the risks there but we need a
comprehensive energy policy that allows
that to happen
and i think part of it is so people
don't recognize that a lot of these
other
industries you know that this that is
what's happening
you do get a lot of support so you know
when you look at solar um
you know subsidies people like oh you're
subsidizing it's upsizing it's like well
actually we can even get to subsidy free
depending on what region and how
expensive
the you know the grid power is in that
area but
but really if you if you want to look at
the whole net value
all of a sudden you know solar is much
more compelling than
it um you know even for the
non-believers
um but i do think that this is something
that we have to
you know it it really i mean it's um
it's it's it's a decision
you know this is not something that um
it's something that we
have not said and i completely agree
with you a lot of people can be critical
of
the chinese government for incentivizing
and
and dropping the prices that low and yes
it was partially by design but
the point is it did it did um grow
the the decrease in prices has really
enabled a much broader market
right and that's exactly what we've
always wanted in solar so solar the
whole value proposition was to
get more and more solar and we have seen
that that has definitely been
didn't have the delivered environment
that we have for oil
we could have any fracking in the
country because of the risks right
at all it wouldn't exist but look where
it's gotten
us yeah and of course there is risk
there
but it's as you said the investment and
then
it's the government right it's not the
free market doesn't do everything
so then do people in this whole industry
foresee the costs
going actually increasing over the next
few years if china or other
decides to like shut down some of the
less efficient companies already
happening
so how will the cost continue to
decrease because of other
advances in manufacturing and technology
and other things
yeah so um you know right now if you
look at the cost
of the solar cell it's um
it's about 50 cents okay
and um and you know it used to be 50
large or something
um and if that's you know that that's
pretty optimized and you know you're
really looking at
how little solar how little silver can
you put on this and
you know how thin can you make the
silicon and you know we went from 200
microns
actually 250 microns of um silicon now
down to like 180 microns
so really trying to get more and more
wafers out of each ingot etc
i find it really hard to see how you can
drive it
less than 45 cents you know that kind of
i mean i really think you're
kind of you're reaching these asymptotes
for cost for
manufacturing on the other hand i think
for like
the installations and for the rest of
the value proposition i think there's a
lot of room in there
and i think that's what you're going to
um you know with more and more
creativity on that front
i think you're going to see deployment
and then also you look at these niche
markets i mean they look very niche and
look kind of like
but you know something like this could
really take off and all of a sudden
there's another there you know that that
um you know
motivates um you know manufacturing
capacity in a different
technology so i think a lot of you know
some of those things can certainly
happen i don't see the
cost of solar cells going up i mean
maybe you know the usual kind of up and
down thing but i don't
i think it's fairly stable and yes they
drop down dramatically and there is a
lot of people in the industry who talk
about how
they were you know kind of fakely low i
mean it wasn't a real price
um but you know there are even outside
of
um you know china where you know you've
got very clean records of
how business is done you can reach to
you know the 50 cent
mark for manufacturing sources so just
that one section
um that i was talking about yes
in the future how competitive do you
think the u.s market of
southwest manufacturing is against the
chinese market
like do you think in the next 10 years
all the manufacturing is going to go to
china
as it's happening in a lot of industries
and it's going to remain
kind of spread around yeah i mean like
what's actually
you know if you want to work install
ourselves in 10 years right here do you
have to move to china
can you stay here yeah it's a great
great question and you know
um um it turns into
a philosophical question rather than a
factual question really
so here i'll share my own personal
philosophy on it if you'd like to
you know hear that um i
think that the um
that there is value in doing local
manufacturing
and i think that if we really looked at
the costs
we would find that there's sufficient
scale there's sufficient automation that
you can have
you know solar manufacturing plants in
places that are
considered to be expensive for
manufacturing yeah they may not be the
absolute cheapest
but if you look at the net net where
you're installing it nearby so that the
the you know the transportation cost for
your end product because this is bulky
stuff
i mean this is not like um you know we
have to like be shipping
um wafers and glass and steel and all
this kind of stuff and so i think if you
look at that there is a case to be made
that the you know the the economics
would support
doing local production um
it's it is debated in the industry um
and um and you know some of the us um
you know um companies started off doing
manufacturing here and then were kind of
moved um to offshore but i think part of
that is also just to capture the market
and take advantage
you know you go to um another country
and guess what
you get a break on the power you get a
break on the water you get a break on
all these things right
you can go to another state and the
government so
you know governments have to to also
decide how what they would like
to have happen in their their states or
their regions
and um and you know you don't know you
don't only go to asia because you can
get the cheap labor there you also go
there because
the um the environment that
that country um you know provides you
is competitive so so i think
in terms of resources yeah i mean
or if it is less effective
i mean so so for example you can um
and there are places where power i mean
because it does take power to make solar
cells
like you we were talking about earlier
um the net net and it depends on which
technology
but um and it's a very hard analysis to
do but basically the
the what the industry is really trying
to um
to fine-tune is the power that goes
into making the solar cell how long is
the payback period
for when it actually generates the power
that it took to make itself
and it's typically um you know two to
three years depending on the technology
and that's from like
from beginning to end but then after
that three years it's all
you know you're in kind of all plus
regime but suppose it is on that order
then you know you can
the if your power you know power in um
across the u.s is different right i
think new york is maybe
you know four or five cents you can get
yeah and uh california
is like 14. um that and power is a big
for
is a substantial cost
of your overall solar cell manufacturing
and so
um so these type of things i think if
you look at them
my feeling is that there's a case to be
made that you can do regional
manufacturing
and it's not just in solar i think that
that you can do in other places as well
it's really the whole thing whole
cheaper labor it's like you know it's
really not about
but personally i don't think it's about
labor um you know
it's about um it's about
incentivizing the right behavior of
the industry
you put um malaysia was one of the main
producers absolutely
i'm assuming it's foreign companies that
go to malaysia to manufacture right
that's exactly what happened it's not
the technology like
china well they have a lot of chinese
companies that are making solar cells
i'm assuming a lot of foreign companies
also do that but it's mainly chinese
companies right that's right right
so malaysia was actually quite um
recognized the opportunity that solar
had
um or that the solar industry had and
they attracted
um you know specifically for solar they
attracted q cells they attracted sun
power
sunpower has a huge facility um they're
you know in malaysia first solar has a
huge plant
um two cells which is now um hanwha
has a plant there so and
again you know malaysia is um of
power is not as expensive as it is in
say singapore
um so there were good reasons for those
companies to be able to go there and
the malaysian government you know
recognize hey this is an opportunity
let's work out the incentives to
to um attract the companies here rather
than they would go somewhere else
world politics here which is uh you know
and we're also
outside the scope into overtime too okay
yeah um but uh well so any other
questions that maybe i'm happy to stay
after class as well but um
but are you able to come back the final
week for the alumni
you know all speakers and alumni reunion
too sure sure
oh that would be lovely yeah more
discussions then too
okay yeah no i think it's very exciting
for me personally to
um to come to you know um to a classroom
and recognize that like
people are so well versed in solar
energy already
um and um and you know i think that it's
a very satisfying area to be part of i
mean think about
being a technologist or engineer
contributing to
an industry that has um you know
a technology uh you can contribute from
a technology perspective has a very
exciting market
and can can make a very big impact in
the world
and not just in you know the developed
world or the
the you know developing countries it's
like all over the world
and um there's not a lot of industries
that actually have all those
parameters and um so so i think it's um
you know for those of you trying to
figure out what you want to do
and where you want to spend your time i
would highly
encourage you to look at this phenomenal
thank you nasreen
are you different yeah so not through
apple um
you know in um in apple my focus is
basically on strategic deals
so you know there may be um but it's not
really
as much solar and um and but i followed
the industry
um you know closely and
and i do think that even that industry
and the people who contribute to the
industry i think
there is a case to be made where you
diversify and you don't just
do seller maybe you do a little bit of
other things too like for example the
equipment manufacturers
you know some of these were they were
doing medical
and solar and semiconductor and then
solar hit them so hard that they started
dropping off the others
and now they're like oh my gosh what
happened to that medical business i had
there maybe i should start that up
right i mean so i think i think from
that perspective there's an opportunity
of you know where i am right now to
support the industry and kind of a
you know um in a different angle that's
ring thank you this was one
thank you so actually
i forgot i had a little quiz here in
fact perfect
yeah there was a basically just um
you know a quick number i mean i you
know i stayed in physics so i
love numbers and some quick takeaways um
here
um so the answer to the next page maybe
i'll just switch to that but basically
efficiencies you know 10 for thin film
20 for
um crystalline it's kind of roundabout
60 gigawatts almost of installed
capacity
52 gigawatts of demand 6.5
in the us itself and a trillion dollar
industry
so some good money to be made
okay
you